how are you agent you gonna I'm doing
good good morning good morning to you
you got your good it's marathon this
whole yeah it was a little tough
football season it is it is learning a
lot though but you're not getting hit no
I probably super got a paper cut yeah
yeah tough for that I had a little Star
Wars band a okay
yeah was that the band aid of choice in
your house yeah it is we only have care
cartoon care that's about to say cuz
normally if I cut myself suddenly I've
got like Princess Papa from strolls
around my absolutes finger yeah we're
we're prize I do I've been on this show
and you guys can attest I've been on
this show with nail polish on my hands
that's true yeah it was a little weird
more masculine how how old is your
you're wearing these shoes right now
what what are on those shoes what shoes
are these right now are those todd so
those products what do you have on right
now what shoes are those these are what
they call red bottoms okay what do you
have oh they because they because the
bottoms are red yeah
alright Christian Louboutin look now
that's a little that's how you roll
that's a little um yes that's one of my
old employers bought me these alright um
so be the Ravens bought you that either
one Carolina Panthers [ __ ] I'm past
it I call it mailbox money why were you
calling that mailbox money I go to
mailbox open it up there's a chat hold
on a second so the Ravens you didn't
have direct deposit from the Ravens yeah
they actually sent you a cheque to their
melt your mailbox I'm old-school guys
like I like notes like checks coming to
the met to the house okay I deposit them
in there and then you know I do some
investments and so you know some checks
I received long years ago mm-hmm
invested some things and okay it's you
still come a residual all right
passive income I understand and now the
NFL Network you and I are compadres for
the NFL media called Oh sex there what
do you
they still pay cash they definitely can
deposit though yes not yeah I don't
remember that the only checks I get in
my mailbox are like the residuals from
CSI Miami that I did like nine years ago
and they're 80 cents or something like
that
really oh yeah pack of gum two packs ago
but I cash you know it's still money how
do you get it though do when you cash at
the bank well I don't Nick owes pennies
um no I just put it right in oh I just
put it right in I would get cash back
you would really 25 cents that's
old-school yes you are old school Stan
Smith you're old school
what do you think of this Super Bowl
matchup what are your thoughts on what
we're gonna see in this building that we
could see through the window well it's a
it's unbelievable this is the first time
I've seen a stadium because I played an
old Metrodome okay the turf the old turf
with the baseball and you know baseball
diamond underneath and then I play with
when they had the artificial went ahead
to the outdoor stadium then I did I
didn't play an outdoor stage okay yeah
all right now so I'm excited to see it
but as far as the game I miss
interesting game is it's fun I haven't
decided yet who I'm gonna who I think
okay he's gonna go I'm trying to go with
half heart half mine just kind of can I
guess which one's the heart and which
one's the mind go ahead okay yeah the
heart is the Eagles the mind is the
Patriots yeah or hold on a minute the
hearts the Patriots because you just
don't want to see the Patriots win
that's that cold heart okay no as as as
the 22 weeks of football I really
learned how to put a side plane right
yes and just really look at the the
analytic and understanding why the teams
are what they are
valuating guys based on what i see on
film based not based on what I've
experienced as a player so that
transformation has been very interesting
and I've seen some so some some flaws in
myself so I've really challenged myself
to really look at teams like what what
flaws you talkin like you know you play
against a
and you see them on film and if you see
him get beat you're like I know why he
got beat right but then going back and
watching the play understanding the
setup of the offense coordinator or the
defense coordinator on why why he was
beat versus going that that guy isn't
very good and this is why I think so but
more making it of why I've seen it based
on a film versus what I so removing the
feigned Steve Smith passion from the
analysis not cause I call it the a hold
myself because you know you see some
plans you go I know what that bum got
burnt right just look at it's like all
he bit on a double move instead of
saying he sucks expecting right sure
your neck then that comes across like
I'm the old player who can't let go of
not playing anymore but so I I don't
want to be that guy and one I want to be
seen as when he goes on there he's gonna
talk he's gonna he gonna say some funny
things he's gonna say some things that
maybe go I'm not sure but understanding
this is my first year and so on I was
doing the Saturday show a couple weeks
ago yeah when we had to spin the wheel
yes
and the Panthers came up and I was like
spinning again no like no no no I said
spin it again because what was the topic
for the wheel it was just like evaluate
the team okay and the problem while I
didn't want to talk about the Panthers
wasn't because of what happened it was
more of there's thirty there's thirty
other teams in the league I don't want
to just be pent into a corner where I
only could talk about the Panthers and
the Ravens but the football gods wanted
you to talk about the pain yes but I
it's my first year so everything I do in
my first year is a precedent sets the
stage okay of everything else so I
didn't want to be just two teams I want
people when they go up there say he has
the ability to evaluate and process and
discuss all 32 teams oh and by the way
he play for the Ravens and play for the
Panthers so headline Steve Smith doesn't
want to be known as a Cam Newton hater
Chris product with that outweigh that
out right now all caps fire mojo
I can never play quarterback I'm not six
foot five I know I know I know hit C and
C Steve Smith will not take cheese you
will not take cheese you're just not
gonna take any cheese it's put out there
I understand try to stay away from there
I'm sick so that said Steve Smith with
your with your analysis eyes what give
me the the way that the Philadelphia
Eagles win this football game in five
days from now well I think the biggest
climate that everybody is not talking
about that I'm talking about is you got
to make you have to make great
adjustments not good adjustments great
adjustments in the second half the New
England Patriots what they have been
able to do this year and and and really
after the Super Bowl win is make
adjustments in the second half they
don't make good adjustment they make
fantastic adjustments in the first part
of the season defense wasn't it was on
pace to give up the most points they
made adjustments all right they fixed
those those rolls they fix those issues
and then you see what happened in
Jacksonville they made some adjustments
and came back yes there was some sloppy
play some errors but you got to be able
to throw the ball for those errors and
sloppy play or penalties to consider to
be existe Belen you got the Steelers
game when they march down the field and
do that made adjustments in the second
half so for the Eagles they have that
they have to put up points and all and
they have to play error-free especially
in the second half they obviously
everybody can make mistakes in the first
half but you don't you don't make it up
in the second half if you make some
errors and in the New England Patriots
our team then the second half they
ratchet up they make they put the
pressure on you they make you I'll make
mistakes well for somebody who has a
Hall of Fame heart stomach passion
chip-on-the-shoulder okay Brady can you
put in perspective what we see from him
in fourth quarters so long in his career
here he is now 40 years old in that
building mm-hmm what does it take
for mere mortals who may not have that
you had it and he has it
what is the it so I'll go out and say
you know we talked you said set me up
perfectly of saying evaluate and all
that stuff hey I'll be a guy to say it I
would have loved to play with him to
play football with Brady you you see
what he's done with guys look at Chris
Hogan what is done for his career his
opportunity I'm not saying that Chris
Hogan isn't a good wide receiver but it
sure helps we have Tom Brady throwing
you the ball your ability to increase
your short career of playing wide
receiver because he didn't play wide
receiver in college he play lacrosse
look what it's done and Danny Amendola
people are talking about Damian Danny
Amendola as if they'd forgotten how he
played in st. Louis he was a good
receiver but he was injury prone yet in
the playoffs in a Super Bowl he's a guy
that's consistently scoring points you
know so what Tom Brady brings to the
table is greatness he is he's
transcendent and way people look and
evaluate quarterbacks the mind is
something that you cannot the mind in
the heart
you can't outweigh there's no combine
that could measure and stick for that
he's done what people wish they can do
wish they could be a part of he is he's
like winning a lotto man you know you
get on that team you die you or that
wire receiver it makes you better
you know he's played with a band of
brothers that you know walk in no one
knows who there are but yet when you
walk out everybody knows that he is I
think he's thrown at least one or two
passes to over 150 sent receivers that's
remarkable so he's great so before we
take a break and then j.b smoove is
gonna come out and we're gonna review
your work and his work from last night
together hanging out Oh that'll be fun
um did the Patriots never reach out to
you they did but you know it just didn't
work out there's some other logistics
and some other things that I preferred
and and so but I have no I'm not like
sitting here saying man I missed
opportunity I love my life i'ma be
honest with my first three thirteen
years in Carolina
you know I was a young man young and
dumb and not really understanding the
economics and also understanding the
business aspect of it but my last three
years I learned a lot in Baltimore I'm a
very appreciative of that opportunity
and I don't have any regrets
you know I've you know they've every
team that I play for they've given me an
opportunity to do something I never
thought I'd do is change the economic
situation for my family for generations
and so I appreciate that allowing my
sons to my sons and daughter and my
daughter go to college based on us
saving that they don't have to catch a
football to go to college they can use
their mind and and rely on that so you
know I'm very appreciative that but I
love ball that was my other than my wife
that was my first love right yeah and I
love watching ball I love talking about
ball and so is it just it's awesome to
be here and see these guys but I don't
I'm not sitting here going man I wish I
was just going like oh this is cool and
I love talking about it and looking at
it without any hate my heart just kind
of enjoying what about after before it
was that a choice maybe even joining the
Patriots I was talking to them when I
was in Baltimore I remember I was in
Charlotte Airport on my way to Baltimore
and I talked to Bill Belichick and you
know I'm supposed to go out there but
honestly what Baltimore had offered me
not financially but what they had
offered me behind closed doors
I wanted that challenge and so I took it
and I mean we were playing possibly
beaten him yeah but that's how to that's
how it goes you know in football we all
sell say ball never lost we they they
intercepted a ball they went on I think
I'm I think I'm straight I'm alright
with it
what was Belichick like on that phone
conversation um he was different than
what you see a little bit more
personality but he was good all right
Steve Smith here on the Rich Eisen show
when we come back JB smooth you're
freaking out
he's a patriot out hey ball is ball
right of course but okay when we come
back JB Smoove we add them to the Steve
Smith mix before Brian Billick joins us
here that's how we're rolling in our
number two here on the Rich Eisen show
eight four four two oh four rich is the
number to dial here
so Steve Smith is here alongside j.b
smoove and I woke up today and I'm
getting ready to go to work and I looked
in the mirror and I see the beard and
I'm like yeah okay I got it
my god I'm like thinking of myself
feeling nice and confident and then
these two you guys get together in our
television only segment you did no not
we
he did yes he did his time come on now
[Laughter]
now it'll be subconscious now he's gonna
see you I think the beer well what is it
is it too long is it just not did I not
shave the cheeks is it
do I need to escape it what I got a GP
tell what do I gotta do that guy who
slept under the tree Rip Van Winkle woke
up with a beard that's how you look
America don't talk about that God know
who Rip Van Winkle yeah now that guy
should have a razor commercial or
something like that he had a full beard
sleep woke up with the beer and that's
it so you did okay Wow now I got to
figure out what to do
post-show okay so you guys were on on
the floor did you guys see each other
last night yeah you're both for media
night correspondent every both look good
last night I'd give I guess give a big
compliment last night okay you know he
was killing the soup yeah is that one
that your your wife she does almost yeah
I know that so she picked this one out
for chili night specifically or well
yeah so I'll just say I'm light-skinned
so all my stuff is I picked out my Super
Bowl soup well two months ago two months
ago yes and you don't do use repeat
suits at all do you do any repeat suits
or no have you worn that Super Bowl suit
at all this yet no I have nice it's been
cinema sue calls it for for a while I've
been looking at the marinade I've been
walking past like this
back in the day I went to my age from
back in the day we will go out to the
club mmm yeah rap show or hip-hop join
we would put our Levi's Elise Lee jeans
between the mattress and let it sit
there for a week open your baby brother
will hold the matches up you lay your
genes between the two mattresses jeans
like that you don't sit down the rest of
the night you walk past a mirror you
walk by the club the clothes you don't
want to mess up you you know what
domestic peace up you don't want to put
wrinkles and you know sneakers mm-hmm
perfect media night correspondent Steve
Smith and ambassador these rules all
right so the let's let's check on some
of your work from last night here Steve
Smith yes I still can't believe James
Harrison it's got Patriot stuff all over
his uniform it's it's crazy to see it
and here you are with James pretty girl
washed up boy the youngest of 14 yes
how are you distributing the tickets
if you pay for them you get them right I
started that since day one that was easy
okay now let's gonna practice bar I was
making $60,000 so there you got the
team's hair saying if you pay for them
you get them and pay for him you get
them they're not stuck you're stuck like
Chuck babe 14 tickets I'm just doing the
math in my head if they're anywhere
remotely close to the 30-yard line
we're talking about with plane tickets
and hotel if he picked it all up we're
talking six figures easy easily yes I
was in Carolina and we played the
Cardinals and playoff game and I got
that I got my check it was more of a
receipt Wow I said this is not a check
and you're right it wasn't it was like
$200 Wow so they took it out of your
check that garnished your wages to pay
for whatever you yeah yeah Wow receive
it allow that is one of the things that
people don't really understand you know
like I've only had the luxury of playing
in LA I play I've only played in San
Diego once and wife we don't want to get
into that so um but I remember I played
in San Diego I purchased so I'll say it
black folks you know that all right come
to the game don't want to show up you
know cuz something happens they think
they crying and telling you and so I end
up I purchase probably 40 tickets 38 of
them showed up yeah yeah 40 tickets 40
folks drove down from from LA it was ton
of tickets I the original number was $52
question but I was after I told my wife
here's so many that you got and then the
rest of them and had my mom do it and
end up being a mess it was a headache to
go play a game in San Diego because all
the people want to want to come so now
this is mental now's like this is so you
imagine what it is for the Super Bowl
can't
it's a expect it's an unrealistic
expectation on guys I mean oh yeah by
the by the way they have to play for the
the biggest game of their career I know
you have a hard out Steve Smith but
before you go here's JB Smoove ooh with
Sean Jeffrey of the where skill o'neill
became Shaquille O'Neal yeah you know
babies who named Shaquille the kids
names right now because the kill O'Neal
crazy that's how we do that's how we
just like how many kids how many kids
are being born named Leon right now a
lot of the our kids so you guys see you
guys don't have unique names there's no
one saying Oh Tom Brady ones football
the name my baby Tom just know how time
is too simple Shaquille our son these
are unique names that people will name
[Music]
is a readily named Steve is my the name
that folks can pronounce well see now
Steve got a name
Wow Steve what's other name my real name
was just three people called me my mom
and my grandma and my wife is actually
Steve on now ste vo in Andy
now Steve on stage Bob BB had you use
had you use that name do you know what
happened in any city you play this
everybody had a baby with a name their
baby Steve all you know what happened
what's up okay what city you playing in
Carolina Baltimore whoever said you
played it that city would have had
babies with that name Santa Monica every
touchdowns going still in black I'm
naming my baby Steve oh well all right
well Steve Steve on now the Rich Eisen
show weekdays at noon eastern on
audience